welcome to this video playing yeah deco
something around those lines dish check
out that I don't know I'm not good with
names did I have this position against
the same player recently I add this
opening with Queenie too long castles
may be against exactly the same player
possible I think that I played a 6b five
and thinking about this again I'm not so
sure why exactly i needed to play a six
the idea of Bishop 36 now was that if he
goes to g3 and interesting the quincy 7
what what are you doing a ends quincy
795 i get i get many i get many pieces
for the Queen
three pieces and he needs to I thought
you needed to do that I mean now I'm I'm
just taking everything off here maybe
yeah maybe this one and I g4 getting
getting f2 yeah a 95 I don't know it
looks looks looks problematic ok so it's
neat that that needs to be played here i
get f to the question is if if i should
take should i take with the night and
take the bishop getting this potentially
strong piece or is this some is this
wrong
one important feature of the position is
that the knight on c3 is not really
playing a useful role yet it can know it
can be very useful on deform putting
pressure on e6 but that's not the case
at the moment i think i just take here
or not night h2 is crazy i can play a
three so i need to take here so should i
take here should i take III where I can
take it almost at any time it cannot
move Knight b-52 deform this is what I
was trying to prevent and I can take
take here anyway maybe you can play
Knight a four-night a form attending a
quick Knight b6 hmm
hmm ah ugly that's not good
huh this is this is really mean I know
it does not mean she gets it back that's
it since it's good rookie six because
it's a check it's a check on I can play
Knight c5 as well now this I think it's
okay i can take with the check and i
have king of 72 to protect it it looks
it looks weird down this la whoopsie
seven-night a form what the heck are men
ah now I need to play this crappy
physician with a dead bishop on c8 ah
unbelievable does this was completely
over this position over and now you have
this is not sincere just night a four I
just need to pay attention one minute to
prevent night a form no I'm not doing
that okay he's just threatening king
king d to walk see one I need to play
you five but I want to do this in a more
appropriate moment moment yeah now I
need to unbelievable this is
heartbreaking to lose this game you just
played come on no words just blundered
completely useless Lee and just leave
gave away f 2 for 4 zip and pepper and
then I'll play a 6 an 8 a 4
rookie seven this is this is really cool
i need to play rook g8 i have no way to
cover
any move besides a six is just winning
this game I'm a central pawn up
now that's a book SF nights it's very
easy winning he will manage that even
with very bad technique what will win
check now i'm continuing i mean he plays
was enough before know what what might
happen check check check
no Roxy to check of course nah yep even
the most lip yeah come on my more news
on this is just just a terribly
frustrating game I mean any other move I
mean it's really I can play anything
here and i'm just a pawn up for for
nothing i just take and whatever
whatever this one I mean and it's just
gone get the King to d6 and just win the
game and I thought well okay can I can
play six and then this crap night a
formula it's just leading to a position
where I'm actually worse unbelievable
unbelievable really really crazy okay
took here I need to return it i mean i
wanted to try to stop still to do
something but there's a look-see tune on
top of all of that this is of course
crazy try to try to still win with Luke
f6 but I mean of course you want to win
after your opponent has given you all
this I mean this is just just very bad
play I was not thinking about defending
here now your various ways to to still
hold it but what the game yeah I TM I'm
just lost I mean this is lost with this
this crazy bishop on c 8 yeah I was I
was I wanted to prevent my idea was to
not immediately take because I can
always take and I wanted to cover wanted
to cover b5 this I didn't want to play
because of Bishop b5 because it gets rid
of all of a defender of e-cigs
so um yeah I can just take and play we
should be seven and that's it his main
main arrow was was 95 which is rather
obviously bad I mean there's there's
various stuff i mean this this was
leading to an edge and this is even
winning we are also possible computer
but i didn't see that this is instantly
winning of course okay but this this is
also good they only move now this is
flat-out losing what he played and this
is what you can do to continue the game
check this is what i meant will i get 3
light square 3 pieces this is also
create for black three pieces are much
stronger than the Queen in this position
so I'm pretty much founded the only way
to lose this game by playing this
chansons oh thanks for watching